[Música]
soy tyler tengo 18 años y soy de
colorado soy instructor de campamento de
verano y guionista mi estilo es una
mezcla entre estilo emo y la ropa que yo
me hago pronto la moda dará un salto con
el estilo vaquero casual y yo tengo aquí
mi propio estilo y también en la parte
de atrás lo ves me encantan las chicas
que les gusta tener su propio estilo
porque las miro y digo esto no lo he
visto antes o incluso una pieza que no
haya visto antes es increíble ver cómo
adoptan su propio sentido de la moda
[Música]
no bien
número 1 por qué decidiste usar botas
vaqueras solía montar a caballo así que
decidí usar botas de vaquero porque va
con mi antiguo y mi nuevo estilo que es
más gótico bien si llegamos a tener una
cita que te gustaría hacer podríamos ir
de compras a un centro comercial y yo
podría elegir un atuendo para mí y tú no
para mí me encanta buena respuesta estoy
aquí diciéndole a la gente que tome nota
número dos por qué decidiste usar esos
zapatos hoy
me gustan mucho las botas así que pensé
que me podrían quedar bien con el
pantalón acampanado bien y giorgios en
una cita conmigo
si te soy sincera soy muy impulsiva así
que me encantaría planificarlo en mi
tiempo libre me gusta conducir
escuchando música así que podríamos
incorporarlo al plan por supuesto duda
bien número 3 me gusta destacar con
pequeñas piezas cuando se trata de mi
oficina porque me gustan mucho los
pequeños detalles clásicos entonces si
tuviéramos nuestra primera cita
seguramente iríamos al autocine porque
es una de las cosas que más me gusta
hacer y yo me puse mis zapatillas
brillantes son geniales favoritos los
uso demasiado y se puede patear a la
gente
y hacer muchas cosas con fabuloso me
gustaría ir a una librería y podríamos
comprar libros el uno al otro
tal vez hacernos listas de reproducción
el uno al otro eso me gusta qué clase de
música te gusta música francesa la
música y gran ser ése es mi comodín
hablas francés de hecho me gusta tu
atuendo se dice ya de tatum y estoy
seguro de que se pronuncia
lo lamento me gusta observar a la gente
adoro los converse sí me gustan mucho
típico de un instructor de campamento de
verano me gusta cuando mi atuendo tiene
dos colores a juego dos colores
principales así que primero usaba el
marrón y luego un poco de base en su
trabajo para mi primera cita perfecta me
gusta mucho ir de picnic así que
preferiría hacer un picnic como a las
tres a las cinco de la tarde número seis
son muy limpias estos son mis dos me
hacen sentir realmente poderosa y como
soy más alta que todos pueden utilizar a
alguien y además atrae a los patinadores
no sé creo que son muy útiles tú y yo
querida juntas podemos decir un par -
dime cuál es tu cita ideal soy una mujer
activa sería muy divertido si pudiéramos
ir juntos a surfear
aunque nunca y además mediante el
gimnasio así que volveremos a hacer
ejercicio de piernas como tijeras no sé
tú decides no hago mucho ejercicio pero
sin duda podría intentarlo
bien
voy a eliminar a la número 4 y me
emociona por el momento existe déjame
ver tu cara
lo lamento por dios me eliminas te por
mis zapatillas y es que no fueron las
zapatillas me las tortillas brillantes
puedes hacer un corazón lo siento
gracias lo lamento me gustan tus pies si
deberías
[Música]
bien
sólo quería preguntarles cuándo quieren
salir con alguien que buscan en un chico
me gusta cuando un chico se siente
seguro cuando a un chico le gusta llevar
ropa femenina eso es realmente atractivo
creo que lo que más me gusta de la moda
es ver a la gente romper con lo que los
demás piensan que es moda esa es la
parte genial número 2 que buscas en un
chico puedes decirme por favor me gusta
probar diferentes estilos de ropa y
experimentar con eso y si puedo
encontrar a alguien a quien también le
guste eso sería lo mejor de ambos mundos
eso es increíble número 3 en primer
lugar solo quiero asegurarme de que se
siente en confianza y que no tenga miedo
de decir lo que piensa cuando se trata
de moda también me encanta cuando se
expresa en un nivel diferente con una
emoción más profunda y oscura lo primero
que veo es su sonrisa cuando alguien
tiene una sonrisa bonita se puede decir
que es una buena persona sé que es un
poco raro pero me encanta cuando los
chicos sufren overall no sé por qué pero
es algo muy ataquen bien eso me gusta
bien creo que voy a eliminar a la número
lo siento lo abrazarte gracias me
encanta tu atuendo
es increíble todo encaja si te hubiera
visto desde el principio definitivamente
te dejaría quedarte más tiempo tu
atuendo es genial me gusta mucho sí
adoro tu atuendo y me encanta lo que
eres
así es fue muy triste tener que
eliminarla es muy dulce
bien creo que voy a eliminar a la número
3 muy bien
adiós
gracias me encanta tu collar puedo verlo
sí
muy bien
[Música]
número 1 si he tenido un mal día digamos
que fue así como interactuar tías
conmigo hoy que me dirías cómo me
tratarían seguramente te preguntaría qué
pasa por qué te sientes así y luego
dependiendo de cómo reacciones te
preguntaría si quieres que te dejen solo
o si quieres que te hable sin que te
ayude al gusto me gusta mucho que sea
sincera eso es importante me gusta dar
regalos así que seguramente te regale un
pequeño y lo ponga sobre la mesa y que
diga aquí tienes a gusto martin sheen
genial o algo así yo empezaría a
ofrecerte cosas digamos como un sol o el
café o si lo tengo tal vez su sigue y
personalmente mi lenguaje de amor es el
contacto físico así que siempre quiero
acurrucarse con alguien a ver películas
y esas cosas y simplemente no sé me
gustan los abrazos eso va conmigo
más
bien eliminaré a la número 2
lo lamento
lo siento mucho
lo lamento me encanta
me encanta todo de ti eso te queda
increíble no puedo darte los ojos
gracias gracias de verdad ahí quedan las
dos
debo tomarme un segundo para pensarlo es
difícil
si realmente tendré que pensarlo muy
bien voy a tomarme un segundo es difícil
no creo que voy a eliminar a la número
2 no fue una decisión fácil de tomar
lo lamento mucho me encanta tu atuendo y
era linda
estás listo para conocer a tu cita sí
señor
eres justamente como imagina cantante
esta te encanta me encanta tu atuendo a
esto me refiero cuando digo vaquero
casual este es el futuro de la moda bien
vamos a posar somos todos unos iconos
de hecho todos vamos a un muy bien
divertiremos
[Música]